the first animal Lucifer the little
black Kitty I really liked him despite
the fact that he did not give him about
me the second animal I met was Shadow
the little Yorkie who decided to put all
of his business all over the scene in
front of me did not love that but he was
very cute the third animal yeska the big
beautiful husky with all that energy
it's gonna be yes stuff I think that the
dedication to spend you know so much
time and effort on your furry friend I
think that that's very attractive hi
nice to meet you I'm CL you have a great
dog thank you thank you yeah so do you
want to go on a date oh for sure I'm
done we are here
and we're just vibing